there is no amount of athletic training
that could prepare anybody for the
bleacher report dizzy-bat
obstacle course we got four guys here d1
bound all of them
you're gonna give it your best shot
D'Angelo Owens three on will
10 spins at the start and five spins at
the end of your leg five-second penalty
is littered throughout this course
fastest tag team relay time wins
everybody ready let's go go one two
three four nice hey tennis ball tennis
ball boobs in the phone booth miss
Nicole doing good doing good get to the
ladder
come here ten farmers missed five more
spins one two four five keep the field
goal don't worry on the back kick the
field goal Oh fine second bet oligo tag
will Will's in one to nine
dad get dizzy with the will get dizzy
with it oh let's take it badly
one two three four five pickleball you
the pinata
oh go tackle that I died
oh my goodness go one Mario knack for
nine ten tennis ball tennis ball tennis
ball tennis balls you got one one would
fit four five Picabo go
he made it go dad go deck okay
dazzles in one dude good ten my god
Jake you said Jake a set can be knocked
down can't be knocked down
you gotta move you gotta move Augusto
ladder ladder ladder ladder low wood
four five big old football in the pinata
big of a football hit the pinata
arrival time did you know the candy down
yeah Owen
D'Angelo you guys about 101 Brianna and
will 59 seconds but with two five-second
penalty the winner D'Angelo and